d'abord
il va falloir réfléchir au statut de
certains territoires
alors c'est un jacobin je voulais dit au
début qui vous parle mais voyez vous
j'ai observé ce qui se passait en corse
j'ai fais partie des gens jeu devant
vous je le fais en toute transparence
qui dans le passé a eu des propos assez
sévère sur la corse
mais après je suis un démocrate
la république ne vaut que si on les aime
et si on est prêt à y participer
comme elle est on va forcer les gens
c'est impossible je l'observé dans ma
vie ce que ça veut dire vouloir forcer
les gens
l'algérie vouloir forcer les gens la
calédonie avec la troupe qui cantonnait
mois président j'avais fait ça jamais
jamais on n'a jamais fait nation avec ce
type de méthode alors la corse a voté à
trois reprises pour des élus
autonomistes et massivement trois sur
quatre de leurs députés je m'incline
jeux machines et je pense que
l'application de l'article 74 de la
constitution qui rapprocherait la corse
de la situation de la polynésie
française et de la rendre et peut donc
pas moins française que la polynésie est
la solution qui est adapté et d'ailleurs
c'est leur demande peut-être que ça
n'est pas le plus urgent dans le moment
il ya une série de questions à régler
mais c'est la demande des élus corses et
2 de l'assemblée du territoire c'est
pour vous dire que nous avons quelques
questions pendantes comme celle là ce
n'est pas les seuls je sais que le
président de la région martinique le
président de la région guyane le
président de la région que de la
collectivité de corse discutent entre
eux pour faire une proposition commune
on verra ce qu'il nous propose mais
attendez vous à ce que cette question
revienne
[Musique]